vor rund anderthalb jahren erschoss der
neuseeländer brendon talent 51 menschen
in zwei moscheen in christchurch
er richtete brutal muslimische frauen
männer und kinder hin und streamt das
massaker live im internet es ist das
brutalste attentat in der geschichte
neuseelands das motiv des
rechtsextremisten purer hass auf muslime
jetzt wurde brannten teran zu
lebenslanger haft verurteilt zuvor hatte
sich der christchurch attentäter
schuldig bekannt premierministerin
anderen begrüßt die lebenslange
haftstrafe sie sagt ich hoffe heute ist
der letzte tag an dem wir anders haben
den namen des terroristen auszusprechen
er verdient völlige stille auf
lebenszeit